bullies what
[Music]
this is oddly ominous okay okay this is
okay this is okay I'm just gonna just go
with what I think I should do which is
open the gift I'd like to assume there's
no instruction here am I allowed to
touch stuff is an elaborate prank
I tell you something today is my
birthday oh my god wait
it's the moved out shoes Oh doesn't me
so mean if it's just the [ __ ] is this
really mine yeah this was the dream for
me
the one big tragic joke of my childhood
is that I never got a Power Wheels it
was the one thing I always wanted
we sure couldn't afford it which in
retrospect I feel bad now as I'm talking
to our mom feeling like Christmas Wow
I needed this I've been having a really
deep can I keep these is that a part of
this okay this is my favorite thing ever
my mom always told me that these are
gonna like break my foot because I asked
her like every Christmas and like me my
brother were really rowdy in destructive
so she never let this happen and now I'm
an adult so suck it mom I can do what I
want
oh wow this is a lot more involved than
I thought it was gonna be
it's a Jeep which is a huge deal for me
I actually love jeeps specifically ace
to have a Jeep I'm a little bit Jeep
obsessed if I were to get a Power Wheels
it would be this Jeep oh so this is what
it looks like on the inside of the box
I've never known there's a lot of pieces
look how many bands too hard to put bit
sticking it's like a million of these
these are like all slimy like I feel
like it could literally grease my scalp
with this I don't know the people Gries
they're Scouts
sort of thing as a kid I really like
these because I was always interested in
space and the thought of like feeling
like I could walk on the moon
like really made me just excited this is
significantly more complicated than I
thought it would be to put together
I would actually appreciate some help if
you guys wouldn't mind okay so we
finished putting it together I just got
to add the battery which is the final
step to making this a real honest-to-god
car wheels
there's like a little cage I didn't read
the instructions at first I was advised
to repeat instructions and if you wait
oh 160 and up which you know I am over
160 pounds cuz I'm an adult I'm just
posed to put five more bands per slot
about 500 so I hope I don't just like a
step on this and fall straight yeah my
mom always said these are dangerous and
how was she know she's never walked in
them alright I'm a little larger now
than when I first requested this some
ominous pops man shut up - like the
parents that did put these together for
their kids because a it's really
complicated but be like if it messes up
you like mrs. screw that's dangerous
okay I don't hear I'm after Oh God I'm
also noticing there's not a brake pedal
there's just one pedal my toes hang over
this I'm gonna break an ankle okay well
okay okay holy the cars okay wait
standing still is like almost impossible
I do I want to say not only just the toy
that I wanted forever when I was a kid
and not only is today my actual birthday
but I had to sell my beloved actual red
Jeep in order to move to LA in the first
place before I started working here so
this is like all sorts of layers of
heartstrings for me here we go I jump
like that this is probably the most fun
I've had in quite some time I'm not a
breath and I'm glad I can cancel my gym
membership now cuz this is it this is
fun but Jesus okay it's a little awkward
for my size but I the magic is still
there for me this is absolutely a
childhood dream come true
[Music]